well the lawyers are getting involved
the Hans Neiman Magnus Carlson chess
cheating drama has been going on for
almost two months now every development
seemed to take the story to Crazy New
Heights and this one is no exception
Hans Neiman is now suing Magnus Carlson
and others for over a hundred million
dollars once again let's get into it
all right a lot of you guys watching
this video will probably have seen all
our videos on this but there are some of
you out there who missed a couple
perhaps because you weren't subscribed
to the channel so make sure you are
subscribed to us if you haven't done so
already and if you found this video
informative leave us a like we really do
appreciate it cheers okay so if you've
watched any of my other videos on this
you'll know that I like to do a quick
run through of what's previously
happened I'm going to assume here that
everyone knows at least something about
what's happened over the past couple of
months so let's make this really really
quick on September 4th at the singfield
cup 19 year old American chess
Grandmaster Hans Neiman shocked the
chess Community by beating 31 year old
Magnus Carlson who many believe to be
the greatest chess player of all time
the next day Magnus announced he
withdrawn from the tournament via a
cryptic tweet of the famous Jose
Mourinho if I speak I'm in big trouble
clip the implication taken by many was
that Magnus was accusing hands of
cheating this included magnus's longtime
rival and twitch streamer Hikaru
Nakamura who spoke at length on his
stream about the accusations and
magnus's potential mindset at the time
Hans admitted to cheating in online
games when he was 12 and 16 but wanted
to make it clear that he'd never cheat
again especially in the over-the-board
tournament game like this one in the
absence of any concrete proof of
cheating speculation reached bizarre
levels including a theory that Hans used
anal bees to receive signals for which
moves to make in the infamous Magnus
game on September 19th the pair faced
off in the Julius bear generation cup
but Magnus resigned in protest after one
move a week later Magnus released an
official statement stating he believed
Hans had cheated more and more recently
than he had publicly admitted and that
he was not willing to play against him
October 4th sawchess.com released their
official report on Hans Neiman in which
they said based on statistical analysis
that Hans likely cheated in more than
100 online games but that they found no
concrete evidence of him using cheats in
any over-the-board games including the
one with Magnus the following day Han
seemed to address the latest development
by stating that his chest would do the
talking for him but as it turns out
sometimes you need a little bit more
than chess to do the talking last
Thursday Hans filed a lawsuit in the U.S
state of Missouri against three
plaintiffs Magnus his chess app company
playmagnus chess.com's chief officer
Daniel wrench and Hikaru Nakamura the
suit Begins by saying quote Neiman is a
19 year old self-taught chess Prodigy he
brings this action to recover from the
devastating damages that defendants have
inflicted upon his reputation career and
Life by egregiously defaming him and
unlawfully colluding to Blacklist him
from the profession to which he has
dedicated his life the suit then talks
about hans's passion for chess and how
up until recently he'd been living out
of a suitcase traveling the world to
compete in chess tournaments he then
moves on to discuss Magnus Carlson and
states that he exploited his notoriety
and success to create play Magnus and
the hands was once a brand ambassador
for them they then know chess.com's
August 2022 agreement to acquire play
Magnus for 83 million dollars and merge
the companies which the suit alleges is
an attempt to monopolize the Chess World
they alleged that Magnus did this to
solidify his position as King of Chess
Because he believes that when it comes
to chess he can do whatever he wants and
get away with it so you might be
wondering why chess.com play Magnus and
Hikaru are all being mentioned here
after all this is supposed to just be
about Hans versus Magnus right well at
the Crux of this suit is the belief that
the various defendants haven't just
happened to oppose Hans separately but
that they acted together they state that
the Banning of hands from chess.com
events was done in collusion with Magnus
to lend Credence to his cheating
accusations they said Hikaru as a
streaming partner of chess.com colluded
with both Magnus and chess.com when
creating content that amplify the
allegations and the chess.com executive
Danny wrench issued defamatory press
releases and reports which falsely
accuse hands of lying in his single
field cup interview in order to bolster
magnus's implication of Hans cheating in
his loss to him okay so Hans and his
legal team are putting forward the case
that these people conspire together to
destroy Hunter's career in its prime and
that they quote ruined his life they
state that his blacklisting from
chess.com and played Magnus tournaments
means that he won't be able to attend
the majority of feed Day events now a
lot of this suit reads as chess.com
being painted as this sort of bully
that's exerting its influence in the
Chess World to determine a player's
success Public Image and exposure it
continually refers to chess.com's
comments as defamatory and its
investigation report as nothing more
than a hit piece Honda's legal team is
seeking damages of no less than a
hundred million dollars from the
defendants for their alleged slander
libel unlawful boycott of hands contract
and business interference and committing
of civil conspiracy now the lawsuit
outlines his case against each of the
defendants in more detail but the one I
found myself skipping to was Hikaru
Nakamura many of you watching this one
of the Hikaru hands appeared to Simply
discuss the events of this controversy
on stream and suggest that it was
obvious why Magnus withdrew from a
single cup after his last hands now
don't get me wrong he certainly has
never come across as hans's friend or
that he has his back throughout any of
this but it was certainly a shock to see
him named as a defendant the suit claims
Hikaru has a well-documented history of
abusing his leverage as a partner of
chess.com to Blacklist competitors
particularly up and coming chess players
it also States Hikaru and Hans had an
acrimonious relationship for years and
the Hikaru viewed Hans as a threat to
his dominance as a chess streamer they
claimed that hikaru's statements on all
of this have been false defamatory and
unsubstantiated okay so that is
apparently what motivated Hikaru to act
against Hans according to his legal team
but what about chess.com well the suit
says that the planned 83 million dollar
merger between chess.com and play Magnus
was threatened by magnus's defeat to
Carlson they theorized that negotiations
would have been ongoing at the time and
that the loss would have affected the
merger and jeopardized what they
described as chess dot comes Monopoly of
the chess industry in simple terms what
they're saying is that Magnus losing
would have rocked the boat of that deal
they seem to be implying that the
cheating accusation might have been a
way to salvage magnus's reputation at a
crucial time in this business merger as
for magnus's motivations in this
conclusion the lawsuit alleges that
aside from the business motivation we've
already discussed Magnus was simply
embarrassed in fact they say that Hans
defeating Magnus with the black pieces
taunting him during the match and
shattering his 53-game unbeaten streak
which stopped him from reaching a rating
of 2900 were all reasons for him to
accuse hands of cheating which they once
again note happened during the
negotiation of the play Magnus merger
with chess.com I'm not going to go into
every single detail of the 44-page
lawsuit here but to put it simply Hans
and his legal team refute every last
detail and comment that any of the
defendants have made about this over the
past couple of months by doing this
they've hit the ball back over the net
in a big way they're asking the
defendants to prove all any of the
accusations they've made in the past few
months except this time there's a
bankrupting level of money and their
reputation on the line the lawsuit also
provides opinions from what they
describe as chess experts who stated
that there is no evidence that Hans
cheated against Magnus or that he lied
about his previous online play now one
question I've heard floating around is
why is this lawsuit taking place in
Missouri where neither Hans nor any of
the defendants are from there now there
are some theories that this is because
Missouri is a state that allows cameras
into its courtrooms and Hans wants the
world to watch but the Sioux States
Missouri was chosen because a
substantial part of the events took
place there including the singfield cup
where all of this began okay so where
are we now well chess.com has replying
to the lawsuit with a statement from
their lawyers which says hans's
allegations have no merit and that they
look forward to settling the record
straight on behalf of quote its team and
all honest chess players now whether you
believe Hans or not most chapters of
this story have felt like everyone just
bashing hands over the head in the eyes
of the public things have just gone from
bad from worse with every new statement
or report from the people that he's now
suing but this lawsuit might change that
a little bit sure he's unlikely to get
anywhere near the amount he's asking for
in this case but I don't really get the
impression it's to do with money in the
first place it feels like the 100
million is just an arbitrary amount to
convey just how seriously he's taking
what he feels a life ruining accusations
this figure has really set the tone for
the court case already though Hans means
business what he really wants more than
money though is to clear his name but
even that isn't guaranteed you might
think that if the defendants can't prove
their statements were true then Hans
will emerge as the Victor but in reality
these kind of cases often fall apart
because intent to disregard the truth is
missing or at the very least the ability
to prove that disregard Bloomberg
Stephen Carter described in his article
on all of this that Hans will have to
show that the defendant said something
that was untrue and said out of of
malice still it's far from an open and
shut case on either side just like every
other part of this story this could go
anyway at this point but it does feel
like Hans is throwing everything at the
wall and just seeing what sticks what
will success look like for either party
how will this court case shape the
future of Chess is this the beginning of
the end or simply the end of the
beginning I've honestly given up trying
to predict where this story will go next
but when there is more to it I'll see
you right back here
[Music]
thank you